es ist der zweite april 2010 deutsche
soldaten rücken aus und sprengfallen der
taliban aufzuklären
zur mittagszeit geraten sie in einen
hinterhalt werden beschossen
[Musik]
sie fordern verstärkung an auch
augustyniak und aus einen verletzten
kameraden kann er noch aus den
kugelhagel retten dann explodiert eine
bombe direkt neben seinem gepanzerten
fahrzeug der 28 jährige ist sofort tot
das kind und dass diese jetzt so lange
dauert und sie sind augustin max tod
bewegt damals das ganze land deutschland
verneige sich vor ihm so bundeskanzlerin
merkel auf der offiziellen trauerfeier
doch lange hier diese trauer offenbar
nicht an jahrelang kämpften augustin max
familie und freunde dafür dass ein
kleiner platz und seiner heimatstadt
bielefeld nachdem soldaten benannt wird
die bezirksverwaltung stimmte auch zu
doch im august sprach sich die spd
plötzlich dagegen aus die begründung der
genossen man wolle keinen helden
gedenkplatz bild berichtete über diese
entscheidung und am ende ruderte die
partei zurück bei einer sondersitzung
der bezirksverwaltung brackwede stimmte
eine mehrheit der politiker jetzt führt
den vorschlag
man freue sich dass der platz den namen
von martin augustyniak tragen werde
ein cdu politiker zu bild dieser platz
kann künftig ein ort zum nachdenken und
erinnern aber auch von diskussionen
sicherheits politischer und
gesellschaftlicher themen sein
möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit bild
chefreporter maximilian kiewel und mit
der mutter von martin augustyniak ursula
wolf uns auch zugeschaltet frau wolff
bevor wir das politische sprechen
ihr sohn ist in uniform für deutschland
gestorben erzählen sie uns etwas mehr
über ihn was hat ihnen als person
ausgemacht
endeavour geradlinig das war meine
stütze mein ein und alles
wir haben ein gutes verhältnis und hat
schon also als frühchen zur welt
gekommen sind ein grund jetzt gerade
über 51 cm und das kämpfen das hatte ja
hat er schon sein leben lang begleitet
und bei der bundeswehr hatte also der
war soldat mit leib und seele hat dass
ich gut genug lange gesucht und dann
gefunden und ist helfen uns ja es ist
eben mein kind mein einziges und ich bin
stolz dass das jetzt doch ein
gedenkplatz für ihm noch errichtet ist
uns das ist doch ein gutes ende
das letzte mosaikstein noch zugefügt
worden ist also entschuldigen sie ja er
mag es ein happy end wir haben es gerade
gehört am ende jetzt doch gibt es dem
platz mit seinem namen aber das war
nicht einfach es sei jetzt vor kurzem
nicht danach aus was genau ist passiert
seitdem die spd gesagt hatte sie wollen
nicht dass dieser platz nachdem soldaten
genannt wird genau also du hast das
gesagt man muss vielleicht noch mal
zurück springen dieser schrecklichen
anschlag in afghanistan liegt ja schon
zehn jahre zurück seitdem kämpft vor
wolf freunde und angehörige von martin
augustyniak darum dass dieser platz
kommt und es gab eigentlich eine
zustimmung dafür die hat die spd dann in
letzter sekunde im august zurückgezogen
wir haben darüber berichtet auch weil
das einfach ein politischer skandal war
das ist klammheimlich gemacht worden am
frau wulff selbst hat davon aus den
medien erfahren die man hatte sie
angerufen und gesagt es kommt doch nicht
und nun also nach der großen
berichterstattung viele leute haben sich
engagiert da lars klingbeil der
spd-generalsekretär hat sich
eingeschaltet und am ende
hat also die lokale spd führung
eigentlich ist eingeknickt und gestern
abend ab 19 uhr gab es eine
sondersitzung und da ist nun endgültig
entschieden worden war martin
augustyniak platz kommt nach bielefeld
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren